le palais de loire s'offre de nouveaux
publics l'ancien tribunal bâtisse du 19e
siècle a retrouvé son lustre et même
gagné un balcon sur le fleuve nouvel
emblème du vieux le belvédère a été
créée n'existait pas il a été percé
ouvert percée je trouve ça bien qu'ils
aient gardé en même temps caractère
ancien tout en faisant un peu du moderne
je trouve ça très bien et la vue est
juste magnifique
envoyez pas évolué on ne savait pas de
quoi il a
est ce qu'il allait devenir un et donc
c'est bien que la ville malgré le coup
puisse le faire revivre
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir de revoir
quelque chose une renaissance complète
le bâtiment est resté de longs à
l'abandon après sa fermeture en 2009
il a ensuite fallu quatre années de
travaux et près de 6 millions d'euros
pour lui redonner une seconde vie ici
l'ancienne salle d'audience on a gardé
les boiseries entièrement et on les a
juste rénové en peinture une salle de
spectacle fonde en oeuvre notamment vu
le jour à la place de l'ancien grenier
et c'est un lieu fortement inscrit dans
le patrimoine c'est un lieu que tous les
caunois ont connu les anciens conway et
je pense qu'il leur était hyper malvenu
de ne pas justement le rénover
lieu d'accueil le palais de loire sera
aussi un coin de services office de
tourisme permanence administrative salle
de réception vous lui donner vie au
quotidien
il va poursuivre l'histoire bien sûr
parce que maintenant les fera partie de
la vie des conway des gens qui vont
venir sur coin de visiter un restaurant
s'installera également au
rez-de-chaussée dans les prochaines
semaines l'édifice devrait débuter sa
nouvelle vie au printemps pour l'arrivée
des premiers touristes